on the 12th of August we will Mark the
international youth day so quite the
context of anniversaries and in addition
we will speak
the reminder of this year and beginning
of next year for sure and I'm sure that
in the next legislator as well about
this dual impact of the green and
digital transitions they are in 13 they
have a profound impact on the labor
market we will see a completely
different landscape related to the labor
market
and what is also important is that the
context is even more fitting and I think
that we have in the room our reporter
Sarah I've seen her earlier how she is
yeah she's just in front of me
um and we have a and any report by the
European Parliament on job creation the
just transition and impact investment
tomorrow we will have a discussion about
it so so this is really a timely input
into one of the reports that we are
putting forward
now just to to mention the fact that um
the entire discussion that we are having
right now fits perfectly into a wider
context context in which we Define both
the governance the economic governance
with the
revamped reform and investment framework
that we will negotiate probably until
the end of this year
um but at the same time we have several
files that were discussing and and Were
Meant to to discuss the impact
um on the labor markets and related
skills one of the most important one
would be the net net zero industry act
in which our committee has exclusive
competencies related to skills
and I think that it is it is very clear
that in this this climate of change and
ambition
um we will see that the green and
digital transition will bring a lot of
positive effects and we should talk more
and more about these positive effects
but at the same time there will be
shifts there will be job losses and
reallocation of employment no new jobs
will be created
such as in clean energy renovation
Advanced Technologies at the same time
high level of labor shortages
is actually happening right now and job
vacancy rates can be expected 2013 to 23
and 2024 and the questions are what are
the solutions that we have for these
labor shortages
and what are the ways to ensure the
availability of Workforce to for the
jobs of the future how can we make sure
that the jobs and skills are future
proof of these positions we've been
talking in Madrid at the informal ebsco
about
the problem of workers in the care
sector the cares and the fact that the
working conditions are quite inadequate
and we we have a massive shortage in
that field but that's happening in many
other fields and secondly I would say
that equally important for our committee
we will have not only the fact that will
be demand Supply related to the numbers
of jobs but the content of the jobs will
be
completely changed there will be a
different skill set how we can ensure
that these twin transitions are fair and
just and at the same time bring
competitiveness and what's the
opportunity how we can use this
opportunity to create quality jobs with
good working conditions in all sectors
and regions across the EU in order to
have a balanced territorial development
as well so quite big questions and I'm
really pleased that we have today with
our sex person representative of main
actors the social Partners the
commission and our agencies on the
social Partners Maxim was in Madrid with
me and we highlighted very very clear
that the role of the social Partners is
crucial
especially for for broad development
social economic development but for the
issues related to social person and
labor as well so I'm I will start by
giving the floor to the invited guests
after three speakers we will have time
for questions and answers with members
and then I will invite the rest of the
four speakers
I will also like in the end of my
introduction to apologize for the mishap
that we had in terms of not being able
to have enough members last time I'm
really glad that right now we have um uh
the colleagues in the room and and you
have accepted to to give a chance again
to this particular hearing because it's
really important with that
um then with no further Ado I would like
to
invite the first Speaker Esther Goodwin
Brown
Esther leads the circle of jobs
initiative
she's from Netherlands uh she she is
working in a Netherlands Circle economy
in Netherlands and work focuses on
bringing labor market issue to you know
Central to the agenda setting around
circular economy and green policies so
without that um with with that Esther I
think that you're connected online and I
see that there is a presentation that is
right now on the screen so the floor is
yours
thank you very much and good afternoon
and thank you for having inviting us to
have this exchange today about the
relevance of chakra economy to jobs and
the green and digital transitions uh
next slide please
so in a circular economy circular
products and materials are kept in use
for as long as possible at their highest
value and natural citizens are
regenerated so it's a key tool for not
only decarbonizing the EU economy but
also retaining value and creating jobs
and opportunities for Europeans
next slide please
and the employment opportunities
promised by the circular crummy are
closely linked to its labor intensity
which we see increases as you move up
the waste hierarchy from lower value
processes like recycling
to that require fewer jobs to a much
higher value strategies like
remanufacture and reuse
that require much more labor next slide
please
I draw your attention to our definition
of circular jobs which was jointly
developed with the UN environment
program
and here we take a broader definition
than neurostats number of persons
employed in recycling repair rental and
reuse
to also include and thereby encourage
the stimulation of sacroeconomy
activities and other sectors of the
economy that can help to upscale
accelerate the core of the circular
economy involved in closing material
cycles and facilitate the use of
circular products and services by
businesses and consumers
so for example how can we increase the
share of jobs in r d or in digital
technology that are directed towards
secular activities in the economy and
away from linear ones
next slide please
this also demonstrates that sector
economy is both enabled by and supports
the digital transition
digital Technologies can enable and
accelerate circular practices like reuse
and repair
and also help to optimize resource
tracking and decision making
and the central economy also in turn
Fosters innovation in new business
models thereby stimulating the digital
economy
next slide please
and when we look at these shifts as the
chair introduced across sectors
the central economy and as the cell
economy calls for a shift from material
to labor-intensive activities the
largest projected job gains are seen in
Resource Management repair maintenance
services and rebounds from consumer
demand for sharing services
and the sector economy can also be used
as a tool for reigniting
um previous active sectors for example
in post-industrial areas
uh creating jobs for example through
developing Industries in remanufacturing
in lagging regions
and member states that focus on creating
domestic and Regional product markets
for circular products and services can
also expect to benefit from local job
creation
next slide please
from the employment gains projected from
the circle economy at the international
level Europe is seen to benefit from a
first mover advantage and resource
sovereignty as it continues to build
capacity for cycling resources in key
strategic areas and cooperates with its
Partners outside of the EU
and the number of jobs that have been
measured using recorded using the EU
monitoring framework for example hasn't
in fact increased by five percent over
the last 10 years
but the degrees to which we see
differences here between member states
and these job losses and gains to be
spread across will be dependent on some
key enabling factors including
governance governance is already
introduced and levels of adult education
next slide please
as the sector economy promotes the use
and cycling of local and Regional
resources it can encourage the creation
of local jobs through the feedback loop
it creates between different value
chains and Industry stakeholders
and with Place sensitive and more
targeted policy packages that stimulate
multiple sectors at once rather than
solely focusing on recycling
research shows that job creation that
that comes with the central economy can
in fact be channeled to areas of
underemployment
so thereby suggesting a route to level
up the benefits of the European green
deal between lagging a more prosperous
regions
next slide please
so I just like to close with some points
for your consideration about how to
unlock the employment potential of the
circle economy
because we see it coming through but
there is much more to gain
so firstly on job quality it's important
to integrate social requirements
including social protection into new
policies to ensure that the sacral
economy that jobs in the Sacco economy
are safe fairly paid and that they have
the same legal standards being upheld
for Circle economy sectors including for
emerging occupations
targeted skills development towards
lagging regions through vocational
training and strengthening local
Employment Services will help to
redistribute these benefits within and
across member states
on inclusion we encourage the
involvement of labor unions local actors
including those that are currently part
of the extractive industry and working
in rural areas
in the design of central economy
policies to Foster more social
acceptance and inclusion
and finally it's also vital in the
design of these policies we invest in
Impact assessment to determine the
impacts of EU sacroeconomic policies on
its trading partners to ensure the
European Greendale lives up to its
Promises of a just transition full
thank you very much
thank you very much this was an
exceptional time keeping exercise so so
it was six minutes on the clock
so so I really appreciate that but even
more the content and as as there is
already mentioned the importance of
inclusion and involving labor unions I
will now like to give the floor to
Ludovic fit confederal secretary at etuk
uh the European train Union
Confederation Ludovic is responsible
among others for sustainable development
and climate change migration youth
policy non-standard work and the
platform economy Education and Training
quality and non-discrimination to the
week thank you very much good to have
you
um here in the committee please you have
the floor
thank you dragos I'm really happy to
have this discussion uh I think it's a
particular important moment to have it
now as we are in a middle of a heat wave
all over Europe and in the world so it
shows also the concrete effects of
climate change and it also allows us to
think about the concrete effects of the
climate change on the world of work on
the working conditions of workers on the
skills that are need also to adapt to
the new situation so to discuss about
future-proof jobs and skills is also
discussing about the concrete realities
of workers that are outside that are
on in this in the summer in the
construction sector in the public agents
the delivery Riders but also all the
workers that need the support to get
also the the skills so that their employ
their companies can continue to product
without being disrupted by effects of
climate change to beat flots be beat
wildfires
Etc so this is the first point that I
want to uh to say it's that adaptation
should also be at the core of the
discussion uh on a future-proofed jobs
and skills secondly we have of course
also to discuss about mitigation
measures uh how to uh for the green and
digital transition to transform the
industries and discussing in concrete
about the transformation of these
industries not in broad level messages
saying to workers that they have to
adapt they have to be flexible or they
have to be mobile that's not delivering
uh discussing on Broad terms do not
deliver the Concrete Solutions that
companies and workers need what workers
needs it's to of course not be left
behind but also to see concrete
strategies at a national level at
European level at company level at
sector level and at Regional level in
order to develop just transition
strategies that would invest in quality
jobs of tomorrow that would disinvest
in the brown Industries while making
sure that these industries can be
transformed so these are concrete
strategies that are being needed to be
discussed in ecosystems in Industries
like the cement industry in the coal
industry in the aluminum steel industry
Etc this uh there's no one-size-fits all
when it's about discussing the
decarbonation of these different
industries that have a different energy
intensive Productions so it needs for
that I would focus on three elements
having a granular first knowing what's
the challenge of the transition needs a
granular mapping of the change of jobs
due to the digital and green transition
in terms of employment in terms of
skills and in terms of working
conditions not only at European level
but a granular mapping at Regional level
at company level of the effects of the
transformation so that we can design
policies and support to workers and
companies taking into account the
possibilities of investment in regions
and in companies so that we can have
we can avoid desertification of all
regions or migration towards the most uh
the richest country in the EU that would
benefit the most from the transition so
we should avoid that we further X
increase other inequalities between our
countries in the EU secondly we need
just transition strategies I also uh
said that at the beginning but we need
an enabling framework for just
transition strategies to be done so
that's why we think with the Trade union
movement that we would need a directive
that would focus on anticipation of
change and management of change that
would reinforce workers voice in
anticipation of change that would also
focus on designing these concrete just
transition strategies at all the levels
that I explained before finally the
third point and it's a key point for
both workers and for companies it's the
financial resources of course the
private sector will have also to invest
a lot in the transformation but we need
to make sure that the financial
resources are available to allow this
transformation we have a just transition
fund at the EU level that is to narrowed
in its scope and also to limit any in
its in its financing even if it was a
good first start that was needed in
2019 we need to expand the
efforts there we need also to make sure
that all the countries in the EU have
the fiscal capacity to transform also
their economy toward the green and
digital transition and when we look uh
the estimate only four countries in the
EU are in the fiscal capacity to do that
so it links also to the discussion that
you will have in the Autumn on the
stability and growth pact we should come
back to fiscal rules that allow for
Investments to be done in the digital
and green and social transition and
would not lead to a comeback to
austerity finally a key point for us is
that all these Investments and all these
policies that are put in place to
support companies to transform in order
to leave no worker behind should be done
with social conditionality social and
environmental conditionalities that make
sure that public money that go to
support private actors in the day
combination do rest expect human rights
do respect due diligence due respect
labor standards and make sure that the
labor Dimension and discrimination is
that anti-discrimination is at the
center to create quality jobs for the
future for workers in Europe thank you
thank you very much dear Ludovic
um
as we have a dialogue there are two
parties in a dialogue so it's my a great
pleasure to introduce the next speaker
Maxim charruti director social Affairs
Department business Europe vaccine is
responsible for diverse portfolio of
social Affairs and labor market policy
issues he also coordinates business
Europe's engagement the social partner
in the context of the European social
dialogue without further Ado Maxime good
to see you again very short after Madrid
please have the floor
it's a pleasure to see you again after
Madrid indeed and to all the members of
this committee it's a pleasure to be
here and to have this opportunity to
exchange
um of course I also listen to
um Ludovic who is presenting here for
the trade unions and with whom we are
working closely on skills related issues
I mean of course we are at the start of
the European year of skills which means
that we are all now motivated in working
together and making
um good way for concrete results
um and on our side business Europe we
have recently published a statement
which is providing an idea of what we
think should be the priority going
forward which is relating to addressing
labor and skill strategies
um so perhaps to put the context
demography is the main Paradigm change
for us which relates to the number of
available people in our labor markets in
2012 we have we had a working age
population of 269 million people in 2021
to 264. so already a decrease of 5
million
um and this means in terms of employed
people a bit less at 200 million people
who are employed in Europe and the
expectation is that we have a reduction
due to Growing costs of exiters for
retirement on our labor markets which
are not compensated by enough young
people coming into the labor markets and
35 million people less in our working
age population by 2050. when we are
today 264 as I said so um that is of
course a big number and the consequences
are felt differently across Europe in
different countries in view of different
demographic makeups but everywhere it is
an issue and we think also that
um cell country migrations play a useful
role um so this needs to be part of the
solution
um on the other end there is an issue
which should not be underestimated which
is a significantly lower employment
participation of non-eu compared to EU
citizens it is
59.1 percent for non-eu and 74 for EU
and this gap of course is something that
needs to be improved we need to have
more of the migrant populations from
certain countries participating in the
labor markets and I think it's very
important that we look at both the
internal and external dimensions of from
our labor market and skills needs
because of course
what will be needed as Solutions will
need to work for our populations and
there is a need that is important enough
to look into external but we need to
move together with the workers with the
government and that's why we are calling
for a new action plan so the commission
of course is the one that is the the
main action actor to to deliver such an
action plan but we think it should be
done in a tripartite way meaning very
closely with the national governments
and with the social partners and we have
identified seven priority actions
the first action is to reduce inactivity
rates in Europe
um and on this of course we know all of
us um that we are speaking about a group
of people that is very Diversified there
are many women the migrants who are
already in Europe they are of course all
the workers their needs young people not
in education training or employment
um and it may be of course that the the
needs are different for different people
but there is a strong need to give a
second chance to all these people that
may have been discouraged at certain
point and um that are not really
actively looking for a job but that are
available to work and that need the
support of society as well for a good
number of them
um so in order to do that we think that
it would be very important to have an
initiative where the public employment
services are going to work together with
private employment services and as part
of this partnership to be reflected
across Europe in the different countries
and regions that we are able to better
reach out to the enact groups and to
provide tailored solutions for people
individuals to be able to return to the
labor markets and the second action is
Education and Training reforms for
timely and effective updating of
training curricula
the content of learning is crucial and I
think it was commented by Ludovic of
course
um we need to work on this as a priority
because this is where we will have the
future competitiveness and improved
working conditions in future at the same
time uh chair you were mentioning The
Net Zero industry act which is also
noted on our side as an important
initiative what we need to avoid is to
have a product is only limited to a
number of sectors but also to have an
approach that is going to be respectful
of the national competencies in terms of
educational training systems and their
functioning and for that we really think
that there is more to do
um in terms of the the member states
coordination connected to European
semester connected to activities of DG
reform in the commission to support the
member states in improving their
training curricula
um the third action is to improve the
recognition of skills and qualifications
for non-regulated professions and the
force is to improve recognition for
regulated professions I speak about two
actions because they are quite different
the first one is really a national
competence and there it's about trying
to find ways of making the national
systems for recognition better
interoperable at European level but for
the EU it's important to act on
regulated professions because as there
is a directive and you can establish
common training Frameworks for these
regulated professions to improve the
mobility and improve the functioning of
Labor markets I know time is already
running so I will be just saying a few
last words on the external actions that
are for us very important relating to
our needs in Europe I mean there are two
tools which the member states need to
improve one is the shortage occupation
lists which they are using to Target
migration and having a stronger focus on
labor migration and labor market test is
also very important to at the same time
make sure employers can have access to
certain Nationals in an effective way
but also making sure that the workers
are confident that they have access to
the jobs available and that there are
fair solutions to improve the political
acceptance of migration last point for
us is entrepreneurship education which
we think is of course at the basis of
our prosperity and we encourage an
action also on this thank you very much
for your attention and looking forward
to these debates
thank you so five and six there were
those two external actions and seven
ones entrepreneurship just to be sure
good good thank you
um now
uh we we have uh the time to to have the
um The Honorable members in you know
questions and then we'll have the
answers from the speakers so we we have
two meets per member uh slots for each
of the political groups I'm looking to
see if it's anyone from EPP
if not then snd
if not renews
merci book
yes thank you very much Mr chairman dear
dragov
I have two questions
Mr siruti
you were talking about the drop in the
number of uh people working between now
and 2050 and that drop is quite a large
reduction and I'm wondering whether
you've already analyzed the impact of
everything that's digital and the fact
that there will be jobs lost
I don't know what is this going to be
compensated offset somehow so has there
been any quantitative analysis of this
trend because we know there's the uh
we're in transition the digital
transition so that's the first question
although I realized it's probably quite
complex to carry out such analysis
secondly you talked about the importance
of Labor from third countries we know
that there is a European Summit ongoing
at the moment there's a lot of talk
about the migration pact so is this an
issue that you are that is being
addressed thank you next year
um I'm looking to see if Sarah would
like to intervene so please sorry I have
the floor
thanks a lot and thanks for uh for these
very interesting contributions to the
debate and indeed the chair already
mentioned it as a reporter on our ineon
green jobs just transition and impact
Investments is really a very very
important topic to me and I think well
we really need to to anticipate the
green and digital transition today and
not tomorrow and of course that will
pose some risks but I think we can
really turn them into uh into
opportunities to make sure that we
actually create more better and really
locally embedded jobs but
um maybe more specifically to Miss Brown
you mentioned of course the importance
of drop quality so it's not just a
question of the numbers of jobs that we
see that are possible within circular
economy due to indeed the labor
intensity and the fact that we go and
reuse remaining Factor
Etc a lot more than than we do right now
what do you think uh is really key to
make sure uh that we that we have a good
job quality in these new and emerging
sectors uh how can we make sure that
that is the case you also mentioned
um the importance of of impact
assessments one of the things that I'm
um asking for uh within the reports is
really to have a social impact
assessment on all our green policies do
you think that that would actually be
helpful and that that would would make a
real difference
um maybe to uh to Ludovic uh I think we
we agree uh that within uh the
transition and of course you've
mentioned that
um in some sectors jobs uh will change
or get lost
um what do you think is really needed uh
when it comes to social uh safety nets
uh what are specific policy measures you
have in mind to make sure
um that these people are indeed not left
behind
um one of the ideas that we have been
playing with is a sort of job guarantee
scheme do you think when you do
something like that regionally that
could that could really make a
difference
and of course when it comes to uh to the
financing indeeds on on social
conditionality I think we have to have
that on um on all those um those
specific Investments uh for sure and
then maybe to business Europe
um you mentioned
um the importance of reducing the
inactivity rates I'm wondering uh what
concrete uh things could be added
perhaps to make sure that indeed for
instance women could be activated do you
agree that for instance more investments
in child care can really make a
difference there recognition of skills
indeed to uh you mentioned and maybe
more generally I think if we don't uh if
we're not careful or or without
intervention the transition right now
risks to be quite male dominated how can
we make sure that gender equality is
really an equal and integral part of our
green economy strategies and then maybe
finally one of the things that we want
to put forward is mandatory just
transition plans on a company level so
that's both with the workers and the
employees equally in the driver's seats
would you support such an idea coming
from business Europe
thank you very much dear Sarah
um I'm looking to see if there are
questions from we have ECR uh with the
coordinator Elizabeth I would like yes
please you have the floor
uh Tucker
yes thank you very much
um I do have one question uh Who start
with the speaker who started off by the
situation of those workers who are
working outside for example in the
construction sector or seasonal workers
working on farms which is a very
hot issue so
obviously what are the possibilities of
uh Swift change in the case of these
kind of challenges you were talking
about transition and a just and fair
transition
we do know what the plans are we know
what the budget is so perhaps you can
tell us whether there is going to be a
just and fair transition
and whether this is going to revive the
labor market especially for those who
may lose their jobs and here in
particular I'm thinking of the older
workers uh I.E people who are over the
age of 50 because obviously it's going
to be far more difficult for them to
either reskill or upskill
and to be able to find jobs that are
paid equally as well as the ones they
had so this is the whole issue of the
re-skilling retraining of these workers
and uh from your own experience uh and
uh looking at the activities of young
people in trade unions there so this is
uh
I'd like to know whether you feel that
young people
are thinking in terms of joining trade
unions and what is the main aspect
uh are they still interested in joining
trade unions and then from the
representative of business Europe
there are two very important Essie
issues when it comes to the labor market
first of all there's demography we can't
change anything about that or with
remove that issue and then of course
immigration
which could be a solution to the problem
of lack of a lack of workers on the
labor market
you put forward a kind of work plan a
program and you mentioned a couple of
certain steps so which of these steps is
the most important uh which would be the
most effective to see immigrant workers
on the labor market
you've said that there is a very uh low
participation on the labor market of
certain workers is there an immigrant
workers there's a difference between men
and women
um sort of is there the possibility of
people wishing to educate and train or
improving their skills for example when
it comes to women on the labor market
and what about the kind of skills that
um and this for Mrs Goodwin Brown
you were talking about skills do we have
good National practices which could be
shared and disseminated to different
countries thank you
um so thank you very much we will now go
back to the
experts and we will start in the same
order so Esther good in round uh Esther
you you have the for three minutes
please
thank you very much for the question so
um firstly on on job quality so we see
that this is particular need where we
need to look at the current quality the
current jobs in the circular economy or
in sectors that we expect to see uh
increased demand for labor as a result
of the circular economy
um so that we know that as we boost
labor in these sectors and demand for it
um that we're boosting the right type of
jobs this is something that our
organization Circle economy is going to
be embarking on with the international
labor organization and the World Bank
through a new initiative we launched in
June
and we would uh welcome cooperation from
European Union stakeholders to help
ensure that those achievements really do
translate into good quality jobs in the
sacral economy in Europe
um this is also because in a recent
study uh we conducted we found that uh
existing analysis on the quality of jobs
in the circle economy is quite narrow
it's largely focused on operational
health and safety and other aspects of
decent work like Fair enumeration and
social dialogue are not addressed so we
really encourage looking at the full
breadth of decent work aspects taking
inspiration from the ilo's framework
um on impact assessments I yeah do
believe that social impact assessments
are incredibly vital
um and particularly to help assess which
circular economy policies and
interventions can lead to the most
favorable economic and social outcomes
um as we really see that the focus of a
lot of this agroeconomy agenda and
policy designs so far has been a focus
on the technical cycles first and
retrofitting what the the labor
requirements and skills needed next
but we really need to ensure that the
the needs of people their skills are
integrated exante into the design of
these policies
um you know some of what will happen
with a digital transition and the circle
economy is seen as an unknown but we do
know a fair amount we have these big
Ambitions of the European green deal the
secure economy action plan which we use
as a guide we can really be proactive in
building in
um the right sorts of indicators and
measures to ensure social impact is
positive
um and when it comes to National
practices for skills
um this is indeed something we encourage
is sharing within Regional clusters and
within countries uh with similar
Ambitions or similar economic structures
to really look at what is and isn't
working
um a lot of
focus has been recently on the
importance of the vocational training
system and how not only the education
system works but how local and national
government and its agencies are at what
capacity they have to work with the
education system to ensure that the
right sorts of measures are in place
where we still see labor shortages but
also where we see the need for
employment
thank you very much indeed the
particular issue of that would be
tackled a little bit later on because we
have with us
cedefop and Antonia let's let me move to
the social partners and I will start
with Ludovic Ludovic you have the floor
please
so
thank you and
thank you thank you thanks for the the
questions uh so I would like to react on
uh also link to the question of Sylvia
brunette to uh business Europe I think
on the discussion on shortages uh indeed
there's uh in the transition there will
also be
um in some sectors the transformation
will lead to a more uh well less
labor-intensive uh job so it might also
mean that there will be a need for Less
workers in some of of the of the jobs in
some sectors there will be also
important increase of productivity
linked to digitalization so it's also
not completely sure that the number of
active people in Europe will be that
will be need that will be also taking
into account the circular economy uh the
positive impact of Energy savings also
on jobs it might also disincentive
disintensified jobs so that also workers
can live with a work Cloud that is also
possible so I think that's an important
point that we have to take into account
migration of course can be has to or
continue to exist with regular
paraphrase for Labor uh migration but
with making sure that quality jobs and
that there's no ground for labor
exploitation uh in this to the question
of uh Sarah Matthew I think that yes
here I think it's really important to
have strong safety nets to reinforce
social Protection Systems in all member
states to make sure that the transition
will be possible for workers a job
guarantee can of course be discussed I
think the most effective tools have to
be designed with the social partners for
example the uh the the element of free
upskilling and risk healing with will be
at the center of the transformation but
for this you need also 20 C page so
meaning that we need to know and we
support your demand of having just
transition strategies at company level
because you need to know know what will
be the jobs and skills need in five
years in order to train and to make the
workers comfortable to enter in training
so that they can stay in the same
company if it's not possible in the same
company that they can stay in the same
sector and if this is not possible then
thinking about safety nets that would
with a job guarantee maybe help them on
the longer term to go to another sector
but the more you can secure that people
stay in the sectors the better it is
also because that's where the uh their
skills are developed on the question of
MEP Raphael I think on the question of
the temperature it's also an important
topic that we have to tackle now for
example with a legislation that would
ensure that there's maximum temperature
at work for construction sector it's key
as a Mr spill episler who said it was
last week in Madrid I was also a few
days before it was 40 degrees I was
seeing delivery riders in the streets
with no protection a link to the job so
that's where we should have discussions
on uh the need to have equipment for
workers or also uh temperature over
which you cannot work as we have also in
safety nets for uh minimum temperature
under which you cannot work so I think
this is an important point and to
finalize uh just transition for the
moment no there's no just transition
there's a transition but we have the
time to put we need to put urgently in
place the Frameworks that will make sure
that everyone can have uh uh to be
secure in a quality jobs in the
transition and this is what we wait from
policy makers in the year to come so
that the carbonation will mean also
quality jobs for everyone thank you
thank you very much and we right now
move to the to business Europe and to
maximum charity Maxim please
thanks Dragon
um so thanks for the questions to silly
Renee first
um relating to digitalization and and
the potential in terms of having
productivity Improvement that could
compensate for less people
um I mean first we have an agreement as
social Partners on digitalization of
2020 on digitalization and really the
premise is to make this transition as
employment creating as possible so the
intention is to do a transition that is
going to be positive in employment
results
um on the other end of course when we
look at productivity improvements we
need to tap the potential of technology
to support productivity improvements and
that is clear so we need to work on that
um but I think when we look at the
current levels of shortages and when we
see the demographic Trends coming ahead
of us I think we can expect we are going
to face issues so we need to work on it
that's why for us it's a key priority to
have this action plan and on migration
um I mean what is quite positive I think
in the variation past is that you have
this new initiative of a talent pool
and the talent pool is an initiative
that is really focused on labor
migration and this is really about
identifying people from certain
countries who are willing to come to
Europe for work
so you know there are different routes
to migration to Europe and some of them
are European ones some of them are
National ones here it's really a
European coordination which is focused
on labor migration and so I think it has
potentially in increasing the levels of
employment participation of migrants in
future and that's why we are very
supportive of this initiative
then to comment on some of the points by
Sarah mature so dress first to to
highlight that
um of course gender equality is
important and we need to work on it in
different ways but for us there are two
good ways when it comes to participation
in different sectors and also in terms
of skills I mean we have very different
levels of participation of men and women
in different sectors and that is
something we are flagging for many years
it would be good to have more equal
representation of men and women across
sectors
that's the first point the second is we
don't have enough women in stem
scientific technological engineering and
Mathematics and there we have proposed
the target for 2030 to have 25 percent
of graduates tertiary graduates
um as a Target which would go through
having many more women to participate so
that we we move from the 21 of today
um then in terms of dress transition
um I think it is uh of course an
important issue but I don't think we
need to have plans that are set up in
this way I think you have information
and consultation bodies in the companies
that are specifically aiming to do this
kind of consultations with the workers
of course it is not specific to dress
transition but dress transition issues
can very well be taken up into these
information and consultation bodies and
so there I think it's important that
there is a dialogue and culture of
cooperation in the companies but I think
it's better done through the existing
channels that are there and to make good
use of them
um and of course child care we are very
supportive we think it's very important
to have more women participating in
employment
um
a few things perhaps also to highlight
on reduction of inactivity rates where
it could work I think there are
different things that that can be very
helpful one is improving guidance
services having better information for
people to make their choices of
Education and Training and know where
the jobs are when they do these choices
second apprenticeships for adults we
have a culture of apprenticeship that is
for centuries in Europe and it works
well to connect to the labor market
needs and to have good employability of
the the apprentices getting into jobs so
that is working well but we need to
scale it up we need to open it to adults
and in many countries it's not yet the
case so it's really a good way of
progressing as well employers are fully
committed we are providing for 90 of the
Investments every year in adults
Education and Training participation so
that is a very high level but I think as
we have the objective of having more in
future I think the there needs to be
some progress also there and incentives
by policy makers to employers to invest
in skills are very important for the
future so we are also looking into this
and perhaps the last thing to highlight
also to my colleague Ludovic I have
brought some reports which is the
outcome of a joint project of the social
Partners which is a project on skills
Innovation and the provision of an
access to training it is one or two
years ago but it's very relevant and we
encourage you to take one I have taken
10 only but please feel free
thank you very much
I would like to thank all the free
speakers for this very interesting part
of the debate and we right now move to
the interventions of experts and
researchers from our agencies at the
popular fund and Airline also last but
certain not least oecd so let me just
give the floor to Antonio Ryan head of
departments for vocation educational
training and skill setup
manages a team of experts investigating
skill Trends and changes in the world of
work exactly what we are talking here in
support of development implementation of
the Union policy in the field of
vocational education training so without
further Ado we are really interested to
hear you Antonio please you have the
floor yeah thank you let me check if it
works this one
okay
too fast
okay we are ready
so just to say that I I I have to say I
shared the previous speakers I mean the
the chair Maxime Ludovic because I mean
this comprehensive approach because the
the first point to make may be is that
uh the um I mean the approach that we
have to take addressing the issue should
take into account uh that the green and
the digital digital transition are part
of a broader process of change that we
are experiencing so Skilling our people
is important in general I mean it is
important in Europe more than in other
geopolitical context because two things
basically the one that mentioned Maxim
the demography so the population aging
and I will say also our weak
productivity growth so we shouldn't
forget that the Skilling I mean fixing
the skills challenge we have is uh not
an end per se I mean it's important for
many reasons but is also essential for
uh to solving the productivity issue
that we have in Europe This is the maybe
the starting point uh in our forecast I
can show you
just yes in our forecast we can see I
mean that we have a growing uh in the
future growing uh highly skilled
professions that of course will continue
to grow even in the next years but there
is another point also that is very
visible
and and that I mean as you can see
the vast majority of the job openings of
the future will be uh in for replacing
replacement needs so it means that this
will affect basically all areas of the
occupational ladder so the first point
to make is that this
broad
area of of of
broad-based nature of the future jobs is
a key message for educational training
policy
needless to say let's go to to the
digitalization either to say that
the digital
uh of course uh uh as a major role in
changing uh currently the labor market
we don't believe that there is a direct
risk of job losses as a consequence of
the digitalization we what we see is a
task displacement type of effect that
can lead
indirectly to a problem in terms of
employment but this is not in our view
the main point of concern we see that
this type of task displacement may
affect
I mean on the basis of our estimate
about one-third of the European workers
uh and so this is something that can
affect the specialism groups for example
maze for the reason we said before lower
educated some people in the in
occupations that are of low level of
skills in general but any the good news
is that we also see uh how can I say a
task regeneration because so new tasks
new ways of doing things related to
digitalization and this is we actually
see that for most of the workers the
point is more related to the to the
creation of new new tasks rather than to
the destruction of existing tasks
I'm sorry all this to say that of course
the consequences of this process will be
for instance you see that number 45
percent is the the number of European
workers that acknowledge that the
changes currently due to the
digitalization will entail absential
upskilling and Skilling so it's a
something that is uh
important and something that of course
has implications for our policy
let's go to the to the other point about
The Greening
uh here I mean today I I guess uh is
more clear to everyone why the green the
green transition is important and
including two reinforce Europe
independence from some uh external
factors and it's clear also that The
Greening of the economy has implications
in our scenarios we see uh that apart
from the positive effect in terms of of
course
prevention and also reduction of future
costs for remedial action Etc we also
see overall a positive effect in terms
of employment so we have we see an
increase in overall in the long term in
terms of employment or in our case we
estimated 2 million and Alpha as a net
employment effect but I mean 3 million
to million Amino the point is not the
number but is the idea is that the
overall the net effect will be positive
in the short and medium term things are
a bit different we may have ups and
downs we may have in the short term also
of course of course not every area of
the economy will be effective in a
positive way not every sector not every
region this is uh quite clear this is
why we have a special responsibility as
you can see from the pie there also
where the the color represents the um
can I say the degree of
greenification of the different areas of
the of the of the labor market here in
terms of job demands
as you can see we have uh even for the
areas of the economy where we have the
stronger the strongest greenification of
the market we have yes I qualified
demand for high qualified jobs but also
for medium skill the manual semi-manual
occupations
um so as I said that we see a special
responsibility in the case of of The
Greening of the economy stronger I would
say that in the case of the
digitalization and there are a number of
actions that we uh we can do that in
some countries we started to do with the
uh with the new plan with the resilience
and and and and the recovery plan we
know that a large share of the money is
on green is on digital
there are many things that we can do in
the short term in the long term uh here
we have some examples uh maybe the last
point to make is that
I mean many of the things that we should
do in the long term are things that we
should do anyway to improve our the
ability of our educational training
system to be more responsive to the
cleaning of the economy to the
digitalization to the to the financial
crisis to the Kobe than the pandemic to
be able to respond in a better way to
the needs of an evolving and
continuously changing labor market
thank you very much
I think that these presentations are
really opening up the the debate I mean
there are so many things that we should
tackle I mean I feel that I have this
feeling of scratching the surface just
of what he was there and uh
just um
even a couple of hours are not enough to
to even comprehend the
the variety of issues that we're having
so thank you very much Antonio for
underlying this vet perspective on
things let me then invite Tina Weber
research manager from Europe fund Tina
is working on issues such as labor
shortages telework and the right to
disconnect policy measures to mitigate
the impact of the pandemic of the labor
market and why the Society
flexibilization of the labor market and
measures so there's gaps in Social
protection and the involvement of
European Works Council infrastructuring
so Tina you have the floor please
thank you very much jobish for this
invitation to present this important
hearing some of the findings of
eurofound research particularly on labor
shortages but also on the employment
impact of the green and digital
transition next slide please on the
digital transition initially
there are and there have been for a long
time structural shortages in the ICT
sector and in relation to digital skills
and in fact during the pandemic these
have only been aggravated further and
although there has been a growth in
employment in this sector already the EU
is still very short of the 20 million
additional experts in this field that
are going to be needed by 2030 and these
are particularly an area such as Big
Data analysis cyber security and so on
as you will see from this slide
in
2026 of European Enterprises had hard to
fill vacancies that required ICT
specialist skills and that's an increase
of almost three and a half percentage
points since 2014 and the job vacancy
rate in the ICT sector has also
increased in all EU countries with a few
minor exceptions like Ireland Greece and
Croatia and there are also a significant
difference this year between countries
depending on the demand in the labor
market for these kind of skills but
that's against the background that
eurostat data shows that in 2021 only 54
of European adults had basic digital
skills and a Target set for Europe for
2030 is 80 percent so there is still a
long way to go and again very
significant differences between
countries so only 28 percent of adults
in Romania have these basic digital
skills compared to almost 80 percent in
in Finland and the Netherlands next
slide please I also want to come back to
the impact of
the green agenda
um Europe found recently carried out a
study looking at the impact of the fit
for 55 package and that echoed a little
bit what they're calling from
zetaphopper just said that the overall
employment impact is in the region of a
positive growth of 1 million to two and
a half million jobs but of course that
doesn't mean that there isn't going to
be Interruption for individuals in the
labor market as you will see on the next
slide please there will be job losses
and and job growth and somewhat
different sectors so for example a job
losses are going to be found in areas
like Mining and agriculture the main
growth is going to be in the services
sector and in construction and
interestingly
primarily in the low paid in the high
and the higher paid Spectrum so that's
all saw something to be taken into
account next slide please and in fact I
will skip this one so if you go directly
to the next slide which shows that we
have some work to do in order to
overcome challenges because
there is still a somewhat of a lack of
an access to training so close to half
of employees
received some kind of training financed
by their employer in the last 12 months
but again there are significant
differences between countries and maybe
more importantly differences between
workers in different groups so younger
workers and older workers in
particularly and importantly lower
skilled workers and those on fixed term
and temporary contracts are much less
likely to have access to on-the-job
training which is so important to keep
developing skills next slide please I
just want to emphasize something briefly
that has already been said by a number
of speakers
um it's not just about additional
Education and Training uh an important
driver of Labor shortages also job
quality and this shows that
um occupations and sectors which are
most strained tend to have the greatest
labor shortages on the final slide you
just see the the three areas that Euro
found would outline if you can move to
the next slide where policy action can
be taken but this depends very much on
what the drivers of shortage are and
many of these have already been
mentioned so I won't go into detail we
need to do more work to enhance
attractiveness in particular sectors we
need to activate underutilized labor a
point very strongly made also by Maxim
and we need to make better use of
existing labor by improving Education
and Training Systems
thank you
thank you very much especially for for
indicated the few areas for for policy
actions
and I think that it's really fitting to
understand that the data converge
to some extent and you've provided some
segregated some some segregated data as
well so let me
um move to Irene Mandel head of unit
information and Urus at Ella is a head
of units
of the unit called information that
Everest
um she's a place to speak a Wells placed
to speak about Labor shortages because
it's about mobility and and sending
people from One member state to the
other before joining Ella you're in a
work in a police oriented socioeconomic
research in the fields of employment and
labor market as well as entrepreneurship
in the industry analysis at Euro fund
Rene the floor is yours please
thank you for the invitation having the
possibility of also contributing with
some background information to this
certainly very relevant debate let me
just give you a brief introduction or
recap uh you might be aware the European
labor Authority is the youngest of the
employment agencies it was established
in 2019 and by next year it is planned
to have the the full capacity of
conducting all the activities and one of
the activities that Ella has been tasked
with is the European coordination of U.S
which is a network of public and private
Employment Services in 31 countries so
even going beyond the the European Union
and one of the tasks of Uris
it doesn't work this direction this
direction okay so now it works uh one
one of the mandates of eures is that the
U.S regulation of 2016 uh implies that
eures is providing regular information
about Labor shortages and surpluses
including digging deeper for example uh
analyzing the impact of specific
sector-specific regions of honorable
groups in the labor market and so far
this has been done by an annual report
since 2016 the latest version which
deals with the developments of 2022 has
been published this March so it's
comparatively recent comparatively fresh
and you also have here the the link and
the QR code where you can download it if
you want to learn more and the new
feature that was added this year to the
report was an interactive online data
dashboard where you can even deeper into
the data that was collected in see
yourself in which countries in which
sectors in which occupations they have
been identified shortages and surpluses
and we aim to work further on both the
the presentation of the data but also
the quality of the data and also the the
meaningfulness in terms of making it
more analytical rather than just
descriptive now what the latest data
found
is that the main occupations that have
been identified across Europe as
shortages are kind of clustered in four
Big areas which is a construction I.T
care notably health care and more
recently horika and within those uh top
shortages occupation we see some of the
elements that previous speakers have
already mentioned we see some gender
segregation notably under representation
of female workers in the shortages which
for their long-term labor market
integration is not the most positive
sign you see in several not all but in
several of these main shortages
occupations are under representation of
young people that means there is a good
indication that the shortages will
aggravate in the future when the current
Workforce retires and we don't have
enough young people to follow in in
those occupations and we're also not
necessarily really see these shortages
only at the high skilled level in these
occupations but rather at the medium
level notably the ones which are driven
by vocational education and
apprenticeships
now get making the the link to what do
we know for the shortages have they been
caused by uh which particular factors
that again was a feature that was newly
introduced in this report Series in the
latest version and we find there that a
large number of these shortages
occupation they appear on the list year
after year so they are structural they
come back ever and ever again mainly
driven by a demographic change working
conditions and other elements that
previous speakers have been discussed
but we also see that some of the
shortages have been caused by temporary
shocks like the war in Ukraine covet or
similar developments and we also can see
that some of the shortages are quite
directly linked to technological change
and digitalization as well as the
transition to a climate neutral economy
so as regards the digitalization we see
here the the typical suspects of
software engineers and I.T Specialists
while for Greening we see a little bit
more of a mix on the one hand we see the
change in occupation as was mentioned by
Antonio but then we also see the new
occupations emerging for which at the
time being there is not yet sufficient
labor available to to fill these gaps
and also from my side a few
considerations what could be discussed
in terms of policies or recommendations
and food for thought and from what I
have said before as we see that there is
some gender segregation in the shortages
and in the Surplus occupations in spite
of all the work that has already been
done in education but also in labor
market integration policies there still
could be room for uh breaking up this
tender stereotypes in occupations
and that could be done both in Education
and Training but also for example in
career guidance so a role of public and
private Employment Services to
incentivize people to go there for
different options a second Point as we
have seen this dominance in the
shortages occupations not necessarily in
the highly skilled ones but in the
mediums skilled occupations that there
could be further encouragement of
vocational education and training as
well as company-based trainings like
apprenticeships
also by making them more attractive by
also here further debricking these
stereotypes of that they might be of
lower value that a university-based
education and elements like this and a
third idea probably not that surprising
to come from Ila have been passed with
facilitating labor Mobility another
solution could be to look at Mobility as
a solution this could be occupational
Mobility but it could also be Regional
or spatial Mobility either within a
country or cross-border
and with that I stop and look forward
for the discussion thank you thank you
very much
last but certainly not least I would
like to introduce the next speaker
Glenda quintini from the oecd
Glenda leads the skills work at oecd
skills and employability division
looking at how skills needs are changing
in the labor market and identifying
effective policy responses particularly
in the area of adult learning and
on-the-job training issues that have
already been touched here so with that I
would kindly invite Glenda and we are
really glad to have her in this
committee uh so you have therefore
please
be here thank you very much for the for
the invitation so
okay so um let's move that rally to the
next slide uh I guess by being the last
I'm going to repeat some of the things
that have already been said I'll try to
give it a new spin but you'll hear a bit
of the same so first of all I wanted to
look at the impact of the digital and
green transitions on job content and no
skills demand and I think someone made a
very good point before Esther I think
made a very good point that very often
we have not gone straight to uh the
impact of the transition on jobs and on
skills and so for a few years in fact
we've seen the focus being very much on
a way from the labor market implications
so it's good an hour focusing on that
next slide now in terms of
digitalization I think perhaps something
to add to what has been said so far is
that things are changing a lot so with
the Advent of AI a lot of our previous
thinking about what jobs might be
affected by digitalization and with this
I certainly agree with the people who
are speaking spoken before that we're
not so much talking about jobs
completely disappearing but we're
talking about the tasks changing and as
a result people having to adapt to uh to
new tasks and having to acquire new
skills and I think what we've seen in
particular with the Advent of artificial
intelligence is that some Trends have
strengthened so those uh bottlenecks
that were not fully automatable before
such as for example the ability to work
in crime spaces awkward positions finger
dexterity so some types of very precise
let's say manual skills that were not
automatable now are fully automatable
there is now skills that are automatable
and tasks that are automatable that
belong to higher skilled occupations
such as for example even deductive and
inductive reasoning even some aspects of
creativity for example and there are
still a bottlenecks that remain even in
the age of AI although things are
changing very quickly and those are all
the tasks related to complex problems
solving to high level management to
social interactions now next slide
please so if we if we talk about the
green transition we know that that also
will involve important changes in the
labor market and as a result in the
skills that are in demand so the green
policies we estimate will involve job
losses and skills redundancy of course
in some sectors like emission incentive
intensive sectors including either
relatively high paid jobs and an
increase in the demand for skills for
green sector we've heard about the
circular economy than this renewable
energy organic agriculture recycling
of waste products for example so
in in this respect also countries and
firms need to promote the reallocation
of resources between jobs and also the
training of workers uh um between jobs
and those sort of training of workers
within jobs which are changing and next
slide please what we still don't know
very clearly and I think I haven't heard
very compelling arguments from my
colleagues either is whether the green
transition is going to bring about the
same level of massive upskilling that we
have
um we expect from the digital transition
so the jobs being destroyed we can see
are generally low skills manual jobs but
the jobs being created and I think I've
heard that from the previous speakers
tend to be middle school jobs technician
jobs so not necessarily very very high
skilled jobs and in a way this this
brings me to a point that's been made
before that we need to be more precise
about what jobs are being created what
skills are being required I think
include the vehicles management in that
this granular information both in terms
of having precise information but also
granular and geographical levels so at
the regional level is going to be
extremely important next slide please
and some of the shortages are already
emerging I won't spend a lot of time on
this I think my the people giving
presentations before me have been very
clear on what are the shortages at the
moment I I would like to perhaps add
that a lot of the shortages we're seeing
now were also pre-existing the pandemic
although the pandemic has a has
magnified the recovery that's been so
fast as magnified as some of those
Shores which is very main predominantly
in skills that are stem that are magic
medicine for example knowledge digital
skill teaching knowledge as well and
then we have Services primarily on
physical skills now next slide so if we
think of the next slide again actually
let's go straight into it if we think
about the um let's say the challenge in
terms of other learning I want to focus
specifically on adults what we see at
the moment is that most of the of the
jobs ensures that are high skilled so on
average in the EU it's about 60 percent
of shortage occupations that are high
skilled and in some countries it's even
larger than that next slide and what we
see is in fact a big differences across
associomographic groups again this has
been highlighted before so I won't spend
a lot of time there but there are very
very big differences in participation in
lifelong learning access to new careers
across
across groups and notably between the
low skills and high skill but also
between age groups next slide please and
now to conclude so in terms of other
learning what do we see as the main
solution I think there's two aspects of
coverage of participation another
learning that we are very often
refer to one is overall participation
and the other one is the involvement of
groups that are currently
underrepresented which would increase
participation overall I think there's an
important issue to be considered that
these groups are generally face very
high barriers when participating in
training for example they don't have
time to train that's often the biggest
barrier Financial barriers for example
so modular training courses that address
time and distance barrier training leave
to take time of work and financially
incentives are very important and then
of course Maxine has already said have
involved employers are in providing
training but it's also important to
support them further particularly small
and medium Enterprises
uh to to provide more training second
training needs to be aligned to Denise
attorneys seems obvious but it's not
always the case so it's important again
I go back to the point of collecting and
using information on current and future
skill needs that is accurate that is
granular and then
um designing specific programs for those
adults where whose skills are becoming
obsolete and finally of course there's
an there's an issue of quality so adult
learning and training is only useful in
so far as it is actually of good quality
and so designing
a quality assurance Frameworks but also
collecting information on what works
best what quality what type of training
is um gives the best cost benefits ratio
is very important and we do that still
too little and I'll stop here thank you
very much
thank you very much indeed you've added
on top of the sectoral perspective the
skills perspective including non-formal
skills
or actually including attitudes and
things like that which is I think a very
relevant part of the debate and I wish
to to have more opportunities to talk
about that in the European year of
skills but with that let me um
address my colleagues in the room and
and see if there are any questions that
they would like to to ask you so I will
go again in the order of political
groups and uh if Sarah would like to
intervene uh then of course we will be
glad to hear her questions Sarah please
you have the floor
Aaron thanks
important hearing uh I would say that an
increased recognition of skills is of
course uh one of the key issues when it
comes to deepening the uh single Market
in order to to increase European
competitiveness and create more and also
better pay jobs and I think in light of
this I wonder if the panelists would
have any actions or reforms in the area
of validation and recognition of
qualifications and credentials between
the member states that they would see us
key in the uh near future thank you
thank you very much
I'm then going to renew
silvi
merci book yes thank you very much thank
you chairman and I would like to thank
the members of the panel for these
extremely interesting presentations uh
we've learned a lot from all of them I
have a first question
I think it was Mrs Weber who referred to
this but I was quite struck by the fact
that there are considerable differences
between member states
especially when it comes to the level of
digital skills this is an enormous
challenge
because a lot of our European citizens
obviously are not but even at the level
of basic digital skills but we see that
certain mistakes are far more advanced
do we know why this is
should we draw lessons from this for
well positive lessons from certain
member states where there is more
progress
so I don't know whether this is linked
to things like Mobility
or just access well access to transport
access to Networks
because obviously in certain rural areas
we know that there is less access to
these kind of services less access to
Digital Services
so this is as I said that was something
that struck me
the second question I have which I could
address to all the speakers do you have
any information and data specifically on
access to women
um to training moment because in France
I've done a lot of work on this
particular subject
and we have seen that
it's less easy for women to have access
to vocational training during their
lives for various reasons that
for example more tasks when it comes to
children it's not as easy for them to
organize vocational training and I think
this is a decisive factor a decisive
element and this perhaps explains why
there are differences in pay and also
differences in access to certain
professions so I don't know whether you
have any
figures or when it comes to the
difference between men and women
and then finally
do you have any informational elements
relating to investment and here I'm
thinking in particular
uh you madam
when it comes to in working conditions I
investment in working conditions to
improve working conditions
in the case of certain jobs we know that
there is a shortage and there is always
this question relating to working
conditions
and obviously everything that's digital
could have an impact and make certain uh
jobs uh less hard as it were then
check if first I'm going to do a tour
and coming back so uh I will check with
the greens groups and Sarah Mathias
coordinator please sir
yeah thanks chair and uh thanks a lot
for your uh for your very valuable uh
contributions and I think it's clear
um in the year of skills of course uh
that this is a key issue that upskilling
reskilling lifelong learning are indeed
crucial
um elements to make sure that our twin
transition uh succeeds and of course
that means uh that we need to get the
labor market ready and that there will
be a growing need to provide Education
and Training uh in those areas that are
linked to skill gaps in the current
labor markets and of course also in the
future oriented sectors
um but I'm wondering if you agree and in
that sense the numbers that were
mentioned when it comes to the
presentation of Miss Weibel Euro found
there's still a lot of people that don't
have access to training actually if you
would agree that
um if we want to take this reskilling
agenda series that the rights to such a
training should really be an individual
right and lifelong learning should be
part of it and
um that the writer training should also
include paid educational leave so that
we really make sure that the training
doesn't impair for instance the the
words the right to rest or to their
salaries
um and also maybe to to just highlight
because of course skills I agree they
are very important but at the same time
uh if I listen very carefully to uh what
both Euro found and and siliphop say uh
we know that a lot of the labor
shortages that we are seeing today are
indeeds particularly prevalent in those
sectors where we have poor job quality
where we have the challenging working
conditions
um and so on and at the same time I
think it's a study of of sedafa actually
that showed that about 39 of adult EU
employees are today over skilled and
actually trapped in in low quality jobs
so how do we make sure
um when we are talking about this
reskilling agenda that we really invest
in the right skills and we make sure
that people actually end up in good
quality jobs thank you thank you very
much let me just move then to the ECR
group asking the coordinators if she has
any questions please
attack yes yes thank you very much I
would really like
yes I do have some questions that I
would really like to thank the speakers
for their presentations on the changes
that are taking place on the labor
market
because it allows us to have a very
overall uh view of what's going on so
obviously we've seen that these are
quite major changes that are taking
place but
fundamentally the nature of work is
changing which means that the type of
employment is going to change and then
of course the social aspect there are
lots of young workers
we've seen all these Dynamic changes for
example like digitalization so the young
workers are probably going to be more
flexible more mobile
but when it comes to workers
who have been working for 30 uh for what
to 40 years then it's going to be more
difficult for them
they're trying they are obviously trying
to make progress when it comes to
digital skills but it's at a more basic
level so I think there is a need
for a reform of Education
trying to solve the problems that we
face in Education and Training because
obviously we we have to ensure that
people can adapt to what's happening on
the labor market or the in the young
people they have to be properly trained
but then for the older workers who have
been working already for a longer period
then obviously the way they adapt is
going to be different we've heard that
on the labor market five million workers
and we're going to need even more a
further two and a half million in this
particular sector so that's an enormous
Gap
and retraining I don't think or Skilling
is necessarily going to help us
so in the IIT sector it's going to be
very difficult to fill the gap
there's the demographic aspect and we
know that the birth rate is falling
in very many countries and I would like
to go on to agree with the colleague
who was talking about the large
difference that exists between different
member states
because there is a kind of technological
um delay in certain countries they're a
bit further behind
so we've got all these different factors
and these are inequalities which seem to
be becoming ever deeper between the
member states at this level
but they have this has to be taken into
account at the level of the European
Union
because we have to solve the problem of
cheaper and worse Quality Labor
I think the final presentation that we
heard
was taking a look at basic training the
kind of barriers or obstacles to
training or retraining especially when
it comes to higher education so I think
obviously
we have to try and solve that at the
earlier stages of training
if we take a look at the challenges that
are facing as they're so fundamental
that we really have to do something at
the decision making level
um I don't know together with
commissioner Schmidt
um so that we can approach this in the
right way so I think that really should
be a subject for discussion thank you
thank you let me then ask if there are
any other members that would like to
comment or put some questions
if
yes please
but try to stick in the two minutes
thank you
well
on the slide you say 62 percent of
professionals do not request green
skills or very few so
two-thirds of professional
workers only only that's a small amount
of people having
been part of the green
transition so it's two-thirds of the
Economy based on your presentation it
gives me the impression that the green
and digital transition is being
improvised as we go along you say there
are no professionals who can carry out
these tasks
or there are not enough professionals
so how long is it going to take until we
get the professionals
that can help us with these transitions
do you not think it's a bit too late and
these objectives are very ambitious
we've seen that we have
shortcomings in technology
but we don't have the worker profiles to
fill those posts
and what is the role of universities
technological universities why are we
not asking them for help I get the
impression we're not asking them because
they are fully aware of the demands of
like the labor market it seems that
we're artificially pushing towards these
areas without involving the population
you talk about migration as a solution
it gives the impression that there are
people outside our territory that have
these skills
so why do we not adapt to the objectives
of the transition transition so we adapt
them to the
until we have the Technologies or
they're sufficiently mature it seems to
be quite difficult perhaps we need to be
more demanding thank you
just press yes
um so right now we are moving towards
the end part of um
uh our discussion
um we will have the answers by the uh
distinguished experts I would kindly ask
them to try to I know it's complicated
because a wide range of questions but to
try to fit in three minutes and then I
will invite also the European commission
for for for their views on the entire
debate so let me start in the same in
the same order and I will give the
fourth Antonio Ranieri please Anthony
in a sense it's quite simple to wrap up
in in one answer because the the the
solution of all solutions is that we
decide in Europe that in every country
we would like to set up a system of
continuing training and other learning
uh that is open accessible to all people
exactly as we have decided a few decades
ago to do with young people for whom is
totally normal at a certain age to train
to study to learn is totally normal and
this is not always something that has
always existed I mean we decided a
certain point that it was something to
do and maybe in front of the changes
that we can are tangible for all of us
also in our life is not only something a
theory or some study that tell us that
the the reality of the societies and the
economies is changes continuously
quickly the point is no longer that you
now have to change many times job over
time but at your job because changes
every day and continuously so we need to
keep ourselves with something that will
be useful for The Greening of the
economy for the digitalization for the
disruption that will come from Mars I
don't know whatever because we need
something systematic so this is the
solution so to speak to everything I
don't know okay I still have one minute
than that
uh because one point is also uh if we
manage to catch up I mean with the with
the with the changes and because some of
the solutions are it takes time to to to
set up a new system uh recognition
validation I don't know who was uh what
Sarah was mentioning maybe the the point
is something that of course is useful
and would be also quick as a quick
solution for the problem that we have
but it's not quick to set up the system
of recognition and validation if you
have not done in the last 20 years
probably you don't have it even now for
the situation that we have to to tackle
today so this is another example why we
need to think uh big in a sense to think
that we need to set up in in almost
every I mean we we have really few
exception where we can say here in a
country a member states where we have a
A continuing training and Adult Learning
System we have bits and pieces somewhere
but the real systems are are missing
almost everywhere
thank you very much indeed the systemic
solution and indeed also we had two
Sarahs so Sarah Scout asked about the
recognition credentials so so
um just to clarify that let me move uh
further
um Tina Weber European
um so Tina
what's your take on the questions or
ideas that the members have asked and
also if you like to make your final
conclusions
thank you very much I will focus on the
questions that were more directed to my
presentation first of all I was checking
and I would recommend for those of you
who are interested in this uh the latest
version of the European working
conditions telephone survey there was a
question about the access of men and
women to training and if you look at the
data visualization for that there's only
a small difference at the EU level in
terms of men and women that have had
access to training paid by their
employer over the last 12 months it's
only one percentage point but it's very
different from country to Country so for
example for Italy there is a 10
percentage Point difference with many
more men than women having had access to
training paid for by their employer so
if you're interested in that data I
would encourage you to look on the
europhone website there's a very good
data visualization of the ewcts data
then there was a question about the data
I presented on the difference in digital
skills among the adult population I I
imagine there are very many different
reasons for this one relating to the
level of a broadband and other
technology access at the country level
the the level of urban and rural divide
but also the level of
um
this kind of training provision already
within the school system we know that in
many countries there's also a lack of
trainers specifically for digital skills
and then it's also linked to the
requirements of the labor market for
those types of skills
there was a question about
um
how working conditions can be improved
of course
um the the first reaction is always that
there should be an improvement of
salaries and of course that that is the
case and has happened in some countries
there are examples of that but very
often you find that is not enough
um and there are also other ways of
improving working conditions for example
more and more individuals are looking
for greater flexibility in relation to
their working Arrangements when you look
at vacancy notices now more and more
people want a hybrid type working
arrangement want more flexibility in
their working time and we found with the
the
the policies that we studied that when
pay was improved when
the area of the country was not
attractive because of infrastructure
difficulties a lack of investment and
still increasing pay is um not
sufficient
so I think I I'll leave it there in
terms of their questions more directly
addressed to me
thank you thank you very much dear Tina
and we moved to Irena Manuel
um US unit Ella please
thank you I would like to respond to the
question about how can we ensure that we
are investing in in the right skills
um here
um my point would be that uh there is
actually surprisingly little data little
hard facts available to really identify
and measure which occupations which
skills are in shorted which are in
Surplus so here a first recommendation
would be to put more effort in a data
collection in measurement in monitoring
in labor market intelligence and this
not only for today but also for the
future so also an
anticipatory forward-looking identifying
of the needs I'm also taking into
account that it takes time that there
are not that many low skill professions
in shortage that can be done by anyone
anytime so also the medium level needs
some time to be acquired uh so to to
have a kind of a buffer period to also
then as a next step when we know what is
needed to also work on awareness raising
to notably addressing the young people
or those that are in risk of having
skills that are to become obsolete to to
work more here to
create their knowledge about what might
be needed for them in the future to have
a sustainable and future-proof job also
here the the point of the career
guidance comes in again and as a third
level is to this regard would be then
maybe even stronger involvement of the
education system so I think also here uh
the last years have seen a lot of more
cooperation between the economy and and
the education system to to adjust but
notably when we are talking about small
and medium-sized Enterprises they
probably don't have that close access to
universities or there might be more
barriers for for those two type of
actors too to cooperate so there could
be some some work done and a second
question that I want to briefly uh touch
upon is the the question about migration
as a solution so from a labor market
economics logic it would be a kind of a
step-by-step process first you would go
for activating the the resources the
people that you have in the country in
the region uh by either using them more
or by re and upskilling them a second
step would then be fostering mobility
within the country which either could be
occupational or Regional then you would
have the cross-border mobility within
Europe and only then as the last step
they would come there the Third Country
Nationals as a solution that said from
the data that we have from our labor
shortages and surplus report notably
those most structural shortages that
come ever and ever again they are also
very common in the different member
states so here this mobility within a
country or across border within the EU
probably will not solve the issue so
there would be some need for Third
Country migration
thank you thank you very much and we
moved to Glenda quintini from oecd so
please Glenda you have the floor
so thank you very much a very
interesting questions I think I start
from seconding I'd say what Alberto was
saying writers which also goes to answer
one of the question which was is the is
the solution then to have a right to
lifelong learning and I think you know
in the in this context of course as
Albertos was saying Antonio was saying
that we need to have adults you know
Adult Learning Systems in every country
that are set up that are open to
everybody we shouldn't forget though
that the biggest barrier for uh you know
most adults approaching training is the
fact that they find it very difficult to
navigate the options that are open to
them that they don't necessarily see the
value of training for themselves uh that
they don't think maybe they perceive
also some of the barriers that as being
too high for them to retrain so I think
although the rise to training and the
availability of uh um you know effective
other Learning System is going to be
very important for the majority we still
will need some sort of some some
mechanism to outreach to engage with
those who are currently receiving the
least training the same is goes for the
validation and recognition of Prior
learning certainly it is essential many
countries are satitapa over the past few
years but very few people use it so the
issue remains of course most countries
are trying especially those who are
setting it up from from scratch but also
those who have a system that's not being
used they are trying to make it more uh
user-friendly they're trying to simplify
it but again this role of Outreach and
the role of career guidance as Irena was
saying just before you know is very
important because we need to help those
who who do these things the least to
navigate the system and there were also
questions about some of the groups so
there were questions about gender the
questions about all the workers I think
I certainly agree with um the speaker
from neurophant who is saying that uh
you know the difference is by gender are
very small except with in some countries
in Jan on average they're small and in
in many European countries are quite
small but what we see is different
barriers so I didn't go into a lot of
detail but the number one barrier that
people's side when they're not training
is they say they didn't have time either
for work reason or for personal reasons
and women tend to have faced more
barriers due to personal
responsibilities family responsibilities
in general
um so I think it's important to think of
for example design support that covers
indirect costs which could be for some
women especially from underrepresented
groups so who who have cumulative
disadvantage like who are also low
skilled for example and low wage if
they're working then to also cover some
of the indirect costs like for example
Child Care transport and so on and so
forth the discussion for all the workers
I think is interesting because on the
one hand
um I mean it is true that participate in
training a lot less but I think we have
to be conscious of the fact that you
know we shouldn't we we are calling it
lifelong learning but we shouldn't wait
until people are old the story training
so I go back to the idea that lifelong
learning has to be continuous and so
hopefully we don't get for the new
generation to them being uh in the in a
higher Stage Group and now having
received the training they need to keep
their skills
um up up to speed and that may be one
last point on uh you know investing in
the right skills I think Iran again was
mentioning that I think the the I would
like to underscore here the issue of
investing in skills instead of investing
and training for specific occupations
and on the one hand this is important
because we are all trying to make other
Learning System more flexible with
modular training which facilitates
participation by Alice because it takes
less time to just retrain for a specific
skill for a specific skill Gap but also
because it makes sure that we're not
investing on specific jobs that now we
think in 30 years are going to be in
shorter that's very difficult to predict
the future as I'm sure all of you
realize but if we invest in the skills
that enable people to transition between
jobs then we are making an investment
that's very valuable
yes thank you very much indeed
basically we're not investing in jobs I
would say that we investing in skills
means investing in people more or less
so that's that's the the thing that we
are actually trying to to promote here
in European Parliament as well
um I would like right now to thank again
the speakers and to try to have the view
of the European commission we have
Carolina vocational education training
um DG ample set of opportunity in the
European commission so care please you
have the floor
thank you very much chair thank you very
much for organizing this very
interesting debate and to all the
speakers and to the people to the MEPS
there who intervened uh of course is
very timely and relevant for a European
year of skills so uh it's a it's a very
important debate that we are having now
uh I will not react to everything I will
stick to my five minutes but I would
like to to first of all uh talk about
this this framework this comprehensive
framework for the green transition there
was a a call earlier on in the debate
for such a framework I would like to say
we do have uh such a framework at
European level uh it's the council
recommendation on Fair transitions uh to
a climate neutrality that was adopted
last year and it is uh it has different
policy packages skills is of course one
of these policy packages but we have
also many other things that cover
several of the elements that have been
mentioned for example active label
Market policies and working conditions
skills as I said including career
guidance tax benefit and social
protections which also cover things like
investments in Child Care Health Care
long-term care that we have seen are are
important barriers to the to the
participation in training and in the
labor market of certain categories
especially
especially women
we have also access to essential
services including housing so it is a
very comprehensive framework and I I
think Ludovic will also be happy to know
that there is a very strong call to
member states to work in close
cooperation with social Partners when
they develop and Implement these policy
packages and also of course funding and
it's true we have the just transition
funds but we also like to recall that we
have hundreds of billions of Euro in uh
the resilience
facility in the European social fund
European Regional Development Fund so
we're really seeing also how member
states are mobilizing all of these EU
funds and also investing in in in their
national uh funds then I would like to
to conclude on the barriers and the
relevance to training and in this case I
would like first to thank and
congratulate the parliament for the
resolution on vocational training as an
element for employees success and as a
building block for the European economy
in the EU industry 4.0 because it it
showcases the importance of that with
very important recommendations also and
we have seen that a vocational training
is particularly in demand in some
shortage occupation and I would also
like to say that responding also to to
some of the barriers and also to the
relevance of training we have other two
important tools among others at EU level
which are the micro credentials as also
the oecd and Glenda was mentioning the
need for modularity and these are also
trainings that are more accessible to
people because they can really be taken
at the wrong Pace in their own time and
it's easier to put it and mix it into
the work and family life and in line
with one's uh ideas for progression in
in their jobs and careers and the
individual learning accounts which uh is
a very powerful instrument that puts
really uh the individual at the center
of their own training decisions again to
to to try and break down these barriers
and then of course they very much also
agree with the points of uh looking at
Education and Training as a Continuum so
we don't wait have to wait for people to
be in the labor market with not enough
skills or not the relevant skills we
need to start early on we need to invest
in in a kind of transferable skills that
will help people to adopt and then we
need really to continue uh throughout
life and this is really at the core of
the European Euro skills so thank you
very much
thank you thank you very much to the
European commissioner to carry on Dino
we are at the end of our debate
um
I I I still feel that we have only
scratched the surface the the debate is
very very
um
fruitful and and
I think that it's clear that we are not
talking about just a quantity of jobs
but the quality of jobs that has been
outlined by several of the distinguished
speakers
think that it's clear that um
we should not forget that when we talk
about skills and jobs
these are not just absolute statistics
it's about this these are statistics
about people
that have their lives their constraints
their difficulties in pushing further
if we are to go more philosophical today
and the purpose of what we do here is
the pursuit of happiness and good
governance
then it's a very important thing how the
future of skills would actually affect
the motivation The Passion of people to
pursue those skills so we are talking
here mostly about the fact that with a
decent compensation that makes
the job as a good job
but I mean it's not necessarily clear if
you are well paid it's not immediately
meaning that that this is actually a
fulfilling job
so there are some third consideration
that goes in the area of of
philosophy and psychology and and one of
the things that I'm reading these days
and again I had a ton of questions
myself but we will leave that for uh
future interactions that it seems that
we are somehow moving a little bit from
stem oriented
understanding of reality to a more Arts
and Humanities understanding of humanity
I think that
um that AI processes these days
have actually triggered quite
interesting debates about the need for
philosophers and psychologists and
anthropologists so that's kind of an
interesting thing we have pushed and
pushed and pushed technical skills and
so on and right now
we need to push more for what makes
Humanity what it is so this is even a
I would say even more at stake than just
the account accounting and statistics
and moving people from here to there
I think that this this debate that we
are talking about these days on skills
and it's about how we rearrange our
society to face the challenges that we
are having right now and to pursue the
ambition and and this is really
something that we we should dedicate
time Energy Research effort money into
it I I really appreciate and I would
like to thank again the speakers Esther
Goodwin Brown Ludovic
Antonio Ranieri Tina Weber
as well from the commission for for for
their participation I'd like to thank my
colleagues that have made it until the
end of the schedule and I know how busy
things are right now before the summer I
think that this is a really a a nice
thing to have before the summer and some
food for thought and then of course we
need to come back again with a lot of
energy and try to come up with Solutions
or or things that can actually improve
the day that the lives of of the people
and give a better chance for having both
a competitive and Affair economy and and
and socio-economic development so with
that being said I really believe that um
this this debate was really valuable I'm
really glad that it was recorded so
people can find it and your
presentations there experts are really
uh interesting and and I'm I'm you have
left a legacy with that so everyone that
would like to to look further into the
details that of our discussion can can
do that by watching that online with
that again
um thank you very much I would like to
thank the Secretariat uh and the
interpreters for for their work until
quite late in the afternoon and
um let's make it happen the kind of
change that we are talking about today
and
um I'm looking forward to seeing a
bright future that we can maybe shape
together thank you very much
I think
and with that this concludes this
session this part of the session of the
employment and social Affairs committee
and we are going to restart tomorrow at
nine o'clock thank you